former pope benedict xvi failed to take
action against clerics in four cases of
alleged sexual abuse in his native
germany that's the conclusion of a
report by a munich law firm the
archdiocese of munich and freising asked
it to investigate allegations of sexual
abuse between 1945 and 2019. pope
emeritus benedict formerly joseph
ratzinger archbishop of munich has
previously denied wrongdoing over the
cases
essentially he claims a lack of
knowledge of the facts and a lack of
relevance under canon law
in doing so he continues to claim
ignorance even when in our opinion it is
difficult to reconcile this with the
facts of the case
the report says there were at least 497
victims of abuse mainly young males it
accuses cardinal reinhard marx the
current archbishop of munich of
misconduct in two suspected abuse cases
last year pope francis rejected an offer
by him to resign but the new claims have
brought fresh pain for survivors of
abuse in southern germany
clearly it affects me very much on an
emotional level and it's the same area
where the abuse also happened in my
childhood about two hours by train from
munich in a small town and of course
that revives some things from me from
that time
the archdiocese is set to give a full
response to the report next week while
the vaticans put out a statement that
doesn't mention pope benedict saying
it'll evaluate the full report benedict
who's 94 has lived a secluded life in
the vatican since stepping down as
leader of the world's roman catholics in
2013 the first person to do so in 600
years the catholic church has been
damaged by a series of abuse scandals in
countries including australia chile
france ireland and the united states in
germany a study commissioned by the
german bishops conference in 2018
concluded more than 1600 clergymen had
committed some form of sexual abuse
against nearly 4 000 minors the real
number of victims is thought to be much
higher nadim baba al-jazeera